[Music]
parents at a valley school are upset
with pick-up and drop-offs due to
construction that's happening during
school hours yeah sidewalk repairs are
occurring underway at cram middle school
on deer springs way in clayton up in
north las vegas jeremy j ford spoke to
some of the frustrated families
wondering why this started now
[Music]
this is one of the construction areas in
front of cram middle school where the
sidewalks are being repaired and if you
guys look over here what you'll see are
orange cones in the middle of the street
which are causing a problem for parents
when it's time to pick up their children
and this is horrible we have no place to
park evelyn garcia came to crane middle
school more than an hour early to pick
up her sixth grader we need to keep
early from home
park
wait for the kids 45 minutes almost an
hour but school principal gary bugash
tells me they're working to make the
area safer we do have close to a
thousand students that walk or bike to
school
and because of that that corner at
dismissal
becomes very crowded and it becomes a
safety issue with just a four-way stop
sign there he's asking for parents to be
patient while the work gets completed so
this construction
is going to widen our sidewalks it's
going to put a center medium in which we
all know it's not legal to make that
u-turn in a school zone an understanding
by most folks picking up students but
parents say not by the police like they
don't want us to park anywhere and
that's according to several parents
who've gotten tickets waiting for pickup
they gave me two tickets but i'll give
them a friend one for the park and the
front and one for the getter drawn to
the school so i can do nothing to wait
till my daughter come out to get out to
school principal bugas suggests parents
pick up their children further away from
school to avoid heavy traffic and
tickets
jeremy j ford 8 news now